mais nous commencerons par un encadré
sportif l'accident sur la route du tour
hier le tour qui cette année je crois
qu'on peut dire aura deux vainqueurs
celui qui arrivera le premier au terme
de l'épreuve
et puis le malheureux luis ocaña cette
eau cagna espagnol court 1 veut frapper
sur la route alors qu'il était bon
leader patrick chapuis frapper aussi
bien par l'oral que par l'adversité
oui est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que dès
à présent eddy merckx a refusé de porter
le maillot jaune en hommage à ocaña
ocaña nous allons revoir maintenant
cette chute chute qui a été présenté
comme véritablement dramatique mais qui
n'est pas si grave que ça nous allons
devoir civique mans dans la descente du
col de menté l'orage à noyer tout le
paysage et transformé les routes en
patinoires les coureurs roulent sur un
flot de boue les pâtes à des freins
accroche plus sur les jantes des roues
dans ce virage les coureurs en perdition
continue tout droit
c'est là que survient un accident de
cagnes à une première chute en même
temps que merckx les deux hommes se
relève mais où tes mails qui arrive à 40
km heure et bouscule ocaña ocaña semble
souffrir beaucoup transporté par
hélicoptère à mont-de-marsan
il est mise en observation heureusement
le diagnostic est rassurant pas de
fracture seulement de multiples
contusions
claude carré dit ce matin en compagnie
de cagnes a et i d'une donne des
nouvelles pour que nous en sachions plus
pointus document de claude carré n'est
pas encore arrivé peut-être tout à
l'heure on est dans cette clinique à
saint gaudens que le tour de france a
pris fin pour le maillot jaune luis
ocaña ce matin il va mieux le sera ce
soir chez lui avant de marsan avec sa
femme et ses deux enfants
quand l'iss au kenya est né près de
madrid il ya 26 ans est venu à mont de
marsan en 1957
très tôt il aime le vélo professionnel
depuis quatre ans il a gagné l'an
dernier lui livre et le tour d'espagne
le tour de france lui porte pas chance
l'an dernier il était malade
cette année cette chute brutale veut
terriblement
le centre géré les masques les ouvrait
la route et puis à moment donné j'ai vu
quitter la route et pour pas suivre et
je me suis j'étais j'ai vu qu'il y avait
de l'idée puis je me suis jetée dans un
rocher
je lui réponds à vélo mais je me suis
effondrée puis après je n'ai pas vu les
autres coureurs tomber sur vous j'ai
enfin j'ai senti le coup mais je ne vais
pas citer
c'est la troisième fois que je viens
dans les tours et du tour que j'ai pensé
pouvais me revenir sa mort je pense que
c'est vraiment ça le plus mauvais ce
matin c'est quoi c'est une question
d'orgueil de courage c'est en gagnant
c'est mon métier enfin ces [ __ ] c'est
la course
et puis un tour 20e tout c'est quand
même quelque chose pour vous ça métier
comme un autre lignée de tours c'est et
la mort bien faire son métier
pas tout à fait quand même là c'est sûr
on est professionnel m'enfin y'a quand
même les sports sinon pourrait pas faire
une météo sur pourquoi fait-on un métier
aussi du reste comment justement parce
que ça plaît on y retrouve peut-être
qu'on trouvait dans tous chacun à elana
qui font du bruit d'autres font du vélo
et ma foi pour moi le vélo c'est nuit
c'est tout cas les deux longs pourquoi
avez vous commencé à faire du vélo en
faire un métier
au départ c'était quoi une question
d'argent qui est sûre nous doit l'aja
moyen d'arriver non au début on fait
vraiment pas parce qu'on aimait le vélo
ensuite il ya les résultats et puis
ensuite ma foi c'est en fait un métier
et il a deux ans alors que du moment
qu'on parle messieurs professionnel
c'est pour gagner sa vie et on est servi
et au départ randy non non il faut pas
pas alors que les coureurs serré les
hommes riches au contraire je pense que
le ballon n'est pas fini pour certains
vous pourriez faire autre chose avec
autant de plaisir mais je pense que oui
j'avais commencé comme menuisier je
pense que ça servait le même plaisir à
vos cannes hier est-ce que c'est
difficile d'être là oui oui parce que
pour nous il ya beaucoup d'attentes
beaucoup de craintes aussi je savais que
l'état se veut très difficile et tout au
long de minute en minute je suivais à la
radio et est vraiment je craignais très
très pentu mari je finis surtout la
chute je commence pareil à chaque fois
c'est toujours pareil et je vais montrer
très difficile pour nous